hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to flicks and chill -
now we're gonna see the adventure of
Frank or possibly Oh the adventure of
Rose is locked so we only have Frank to
go but that's ok because I got a feeling
that Frank and I are gonna get along
oh so nicely okay why you look like me
why you look like me Frank you force
many to think differently about you that
charge they heavily to your account you
came nigh to them and yet went past from
that thing never what are you talking
about Frank you go beyond them but the
higher you rise the smaller does the I
of envy see you most of all however is
the flying one hatred Oh nish how your
cryptic philosophy speaks to me so
alright number one I'm not such a nerd
as thee and also nish really I always
believed in the other guy
oh hello how's it going hey Tyler hey
Frank readin on the job hey Tyler yeah
yeah he just reading a few quotes to get
me geared up for the next an hour
stretch these quotes are the only thing
to get me through these 12 hour work
days well cut it out we don't have time
for you taking reading breaks oh geez
Tyler ya [ __ ]
my dad didn't start this company so you
can have a leisure time we're here to
make a profit and if you're not gonna
contribute then you're just dead weight
si get the [ __ ] out who do you think
you're talking to [ __ ] do you think you
know I am yeah sorry
that's not what I said I said I have a
lot of anger to vent towards your face
Tyler I'll stop reading you better this
cut better be top notch by the end of
the week or else
alright well better get to it another
cup of coffee will give me up and get me
going I don't think so another another
Fistful of vengeance this game could
take a turn if I just decided to start
murdering everybody here
and whatever cup of coffee it is of crap
there's no coffee how the hell am I
gonna get work done without any coffee
oh yeah we ran out a few hours ago why
don't you go down the cafe and road buy
some give you a chance to take a break
oh thanks Tyler sure I'll take a unicorn
Fraggle Appetit no and make it snappy
yeah sure
alright well but guess it'd better take
your owns orders orders what do I gotta
do that
what can I just get myself and Tyler a
cup of coffee because he asked me and
I'm a nice guy I'll get it for him but
whatever fine hello who are you what do
you want for coffee hey Katie
oh hey Frank Tyler was making you buy
his cough his coffee boy again yeah I
guess so
man I don't know how he expects you to
get this absurd amount of work done if
you're running his errands all the time
you got to stick up for yourself Frank
don't let him push you around like that
yeah you're right yeah you're right I
don't care if I have to quit I could go
for some coffee and fresh air myself to
be honest get out of the sweat shop for
a bit well I love a coffee then black
like my soul you got it
hey you should bring Christina Christina
yeah I think she could use a little bit
of a breather - I was been hitting on
her all day long yeah boy reading on the
job okyou I swear Tyler hired you to
harass him one way and heard of her ass
in another
anyway it's also a bookstore she likes
books just as much as you plus is pretty
obvious you have a crush on her really
yep I swear it's a page out of Beauty
and the Beast and he's like Gaston and
you're like a nerdy beast or something
anyway just ask her if she wants help
with the coffee I'm sure she'd love to
come along just don't mention nish
pretty sure she reads romance books all
day and that stuff is not for the faint
of heart
noted all right face Katy I'm gonna go
pick up this girl only because Tyler
doesn't seem to would probably be pissed
off by it hey Ronnie hey Frank man great
job on your section of the code you're
killing it brother huh Thanks you're
going to the coffee shop yep my latest
critical task by our favorite boss well
if it's on the company dollars I'll take
a latte thanks man
no prob and hey Christina is that what
your name was hey how you doing my
name's Frank you can call me mark though
hey Christina
oh hey Frank was uh I'm getting coffee
would you like to come want to come see
I'm kind of working at the moment plus I
don't drink coffee but thanks for the
offer
what are you reading which book II read
oh this just a silly romance novel you
know girl stuff
romance good cool cool cool cool well
huh hey I'm going to the cafe book store
to grab a coffee for the office you come
with me and get some fresh air if you
want you know what sure why the heck not
I'd love to pick up a new book too if we
have the time yeah sure let's do it
let's play hooky let's let's quit our
jobs and go get married oh so uh how do
you like working here it's all right you
know has its pros and cons there's like
any job and a my bro my bro baby no uh I
know exactly of which you are talking
about he's talking about tile or
yeah I know you mean it's good to have
money but sometimes I feel overworked
overworked is an understatement you seem
to be tasked with quite load quite the
load at the moment you know when I got
the job
I thought the team would be bigger I was
pretty surprised when I found out it was
just three of you
what do you mean Suze the amount of
projects that come through our firm is
huge I thought it was like some big
company or something hmm
yeah that's just me and the guys pretty
impressive huh Wow thank you pretty
impressive okay beautiful day today huh
not it's not as beautiful as you know
are we talking about the weather now no
yeah it's really nice out a good day for
a stroll really looking forward to some
coffee anyway see so what did you do
before this so what did you do before
this believe it or not I was a librarian
smart smart and sexy no that's weird and
yet you like romance novels I didn't
tell her yeah that would be a mistake
because I didn't she didn't tell me that
why aren't you there anymore see I
wasn't get paid enough it was really
nice being around books oh I really miss
it you should do what you love if you
love what you do the money will follow
speak for yourself yeah I do I love what
I do I think in code yeah yeah
sure you love being a coffee boy hmm
yeah I guess you're right hey Who am I
to judge I went from one sitting job to
another still just shuffling around
papers
ask her about her jaw let's talk about
me and my dreams and my things that I
like what are your why your hobbies
so what do you do when you're not
shuffle around Tyler's papers well you
know romance novels tending to my cats
getting to the bark etc etc sounds fun I
love cats oh yeah everyone loves cats
nowadays I'm more of a dog guy true very
very true how much longer till we get
there not too far haven't he been there
before I thought you'd get Tyler's
coffee
I usually just grab Tyler's fancy for a
palapa chinos in my car on the way to
work okay yeah we're almost there you
know those things are horrible for you I
get sick just looking at them huh same
pretty sure they're delicious though oh
absolutely
we're hypocrites aren't we who isn't
this day and age we have so much in
common
let's not get political no one cats cats
are not hypocrites they do exactly what
they say cats hence why the internet
loves them so much they're the perfect
antithesis of the modern adult tre
forward about they're named compact
low-maintenance self-obsessed think that
the center of the universe and expect
others to pick up their poo more like
the perfect counterpart to Millennials
our mirror image really yeah lost
millenials sure never thought of it that
way maybe you're right
trust me I live with one I'm basically
an authority on the subject maybe you
should write a book about it now a New
York Times bestseller author here I come
not sure how you'd make a romance novel
out of that bill it wouldn't be a
romance novel it would be a select
philosophy book the Zen of maintaining a
tiny self-obsessed person hey I like
philosophy apparently Wow sounds pretty
deep I like it here we are
time to get Tyler's unicorn Frappuccino
did you hear about how that was like a
big deal now Tyler doesn't let me read
the news it works he monitors my web
browsing that's unsettling yeah a lot of
things about this job is unsettling but
it yeah all right now get to get the
coffee go for it I'm gonna check out the
books right
who are you stranger how are you doing
hey there oh hey what are you working on
well just making some fliers for open
mic I'm running out another cafe you
want to come sure sounds awesome you
want my phone number or email address I
can send you the flier once it's done
let's see
sure why not cool it's Hecht and no
underscore 64 at we mail Dom I know
email man ascend BBB bills alright sure
Julio hey you're that bartender lady how
you doing can I be a model hey there
alright you're Frank right I've seen you
here before yeah I'm Frank and you are
Theresa
good to meet you Frank okay weird
question but are you like a super
awesome program or something oh yeah
that's me yeah I'm okay awesome you're
totally the guy I'm looking forward to
program my blog programming a blog
that's pretty easy work are you sure you
need my help we really do we're clueless
and definitely need someone professional
on board would you mind helping us and
yet you were trying to hire models for
it already I see the whole story
alright I'll play your game you know I
got a lot on my plate in the moment well
I think I made some time for starting a
blog Oh awesome man yeah it's gonna be
pretty cool did you see well pay you of
course what's your email on the email
you the details its Fatah Kakashi a gig
spot dud meant awesome sending you an
email all right cool all right so
there's something in a weaving story
here I'm about that though I'm about do
how you do how you doing hi there hi
Frank getting your boss to coffee again
yeah he wants to try the unicorn one
everyone keeps talking about lately
sorry Scoob rats we're a local coffee
cafe we sell coffee okay any other day
what I'd like mocha FRAP a lap ochite
I'll go get him nothing get him nothing
not a thing not a goddamn thing you know
what just don't get him anything
you sure Frank won't he like fire you or
something probably gonna get fired
anyway
seems like I'm threatened with it every
day might as well stop prolonging the
inevitable there you go buddy
gee Frank I'm sorry to hear it man it's
life Oh what can I get for you something
sugary too
hurry up let's just take a copy with
cream sugar makes me crash classic guy
all right coffee with green for you
anything for that girl you walked in
with she don't like coffee maybe a green
tea would be good you know what I think
she made like a green tea all right well
how about the rest of your crew lot
safer Ronny black coffee for Katy nice
I'll have those rolling in a bit you can
go check out the books or something
while you wait
sounds good thanks all right see you
around see is he around who are you
hello how's it going in there so I'm
really busy at the moment bad there can
help you if you need something okay see
you busy wiping off something by in the
counter labyrinthian back here in this
bookstore it is Oh
cushy down on this ah that's enough
that's nice
I'll get it I'll get up now okay getting
up nope didn't want to do that not
wanting to get up aren't what I want to
get up thank you
hey how you doing hey find a good book
yet nah still looking see well hurry up
need some help hey Mel hmm I don't know
I'm just kind of browsing unfortunately
we don't have a ton of time I'm gonna
help her pick of something okay I will
help you I am going to help I'm helping
look at me I'm helping helping
apparently I'm not helping over there
help how do I help how can I help you
how can I help
shall I get on this ladder and help
shall I get on this steppy stool all
right how about this huh wow this brings
back memories
what's that Larry blotter in the Wizards
revenge I've never read that he's
serious I thought everyone read those
books not me I wasn't into those kind of
books growing up you didn't miss much
well you should get it this would be an
insult everybody loves these books you
should get it well you should get it
feel like I kind of missed out on the
hype and sans hype it would be kind of
boring no oh it's not be good these
books are the best and these books
basically define my childhood did you
dress up as him and go to the movies I
feel like that's something you would do
maybe just cuz all I would need is a
scar on the forehead now you totally did
I can totally see you with that scar on
your head yeah I was really good time
but what talk about childhood regrets
yeah why not you know I think it's kind
of sad what is well our generation child
is basically defined by a sitting inside
all the time watching cartoons and
playing video games and reading these
silly books previous generations went
outside and played and well feel like
something was missing in my childhood oh
I went outside and played tons you had
the option you just didn't do it you got
strict I don't know I think it's all
right I grew up on a farm most
constantly outside that's great but
sometimes I get the feeling that I
missed out on the other stuff I mean
I've never even played video games
really wow you've never read Larry
blotter and never played video games
you my friend are an anomaly anyway I
recommend this book it's good stuff keep
that in mind
oh there we go that's pleasantries
all right you ready to go yet but fine
then you fiddle around water or whatever
books you're diddling with I'll go over
here and actually make something of my
life
alright who do we get who do we got
going on here whoo yeah
Oh skip my goddamn coffee yet you got my
goddamn coffee where's my goddamn coffee
okay never mind I'm gonna hit thrust
what do I do
Oh am I still supposed to be looking for
books well that's my bad
how cool European Travel Guide
well that sounds pretty cool I've always
wanted to go to Europe
you've never been no but I've always
wanted to have you I would I lie no no
not yet
something you'd be interested in doing
someday absolutely I kidding me love
travel more something I've been dreaming
up for a long time well what's holding
you back well I only have so many
vacation days you know I see hey your
Sweden has a six-hour workday it sounds
like something you would benefit from no
see I'd settle for the typical eight
hours I'd settle for the typical eight I
feel like my time is slipping away from
me yeah I understand how you feel
yeah I'm plus I'm pretty sure it won't
last much longer anyway I've been
working non-stop how much more do we
have left after it extended with a
quarter sprint I'm sure I'll be getting
a promotion or at least some free time
end of the quarter sprint what do you
mean he had a quarter sprint you know
the reason why we have so much projects
right now are you Tyler's secretary you
should know about this I'm Frank I hate
to tell you this but we're not doing any
kind of spring we started we're starting
a client portfolio expansion tile is
trying to double the amount of clients
we have permanently wait what now you
didn't know this oh boy well wait are we
hiring more employees this could be a
good thing I don't think that's time as
planned Frank he keeps talking about
keeping costs low sorry Frank well
that's [ __ ] I quit are you all right
I I don't know do you want to get back
to work then not really
yeah they can wait I don't know which
one would be better they can wait
you know what no Tyler can wait a little
while we're gonna find you a book first
plus this is nice yeah it's really nice
story
Frank coffees good to go okay cool I'll
grab our drinks but let's creep the
browsing a bit yeah let's do that that's
nice now that I've learned the horrible
secret that's keeping us all contained
in this horrible prison we call work
slave our best years of our life away
trying to do someone else's job hello
ello ello ello how's it going how you
doing here you go Frank you know I've
been hearing what you're talking about
you guys are getting pretty deep over
there yeah I know which is bantering
really I don't know it's probably not my
place but you two are cute together oh
thanks I think so too
ah thanks I think so too you gonna ask
her out maybe maybe I don't know maybe
at some point she likes me too
take it from me she likes you I think
she just wants to get to know you do you
know I don't know baby
good luck enjoy the coffee alright okay
alright anybody else need a word of
advice over here hey you want to give me
some advice yeah you know you do you two
are adorable enjoy the coffee huh no
thanks I will throw the coffee that is
Oh let's go be adorable over there
hood doo dee doo doo doo doo doo oh
alright then I can't walk here I'm gonna
walk for me excuse you I brought you a
green tea seriously Oh Frank you didn't
have to do that
but thank you I'll mention it hey so I
was poking around the business section
and check this out starting your own
business for imbeciles yeah I was just
thinking if things don't work out of our
current company
see that's a good idea you know that's a
pretty good idea you really think so
yeah you know if things don't work out
here I could easily start freelancing or
something but to be honest I don't know
I think about running a business
hence the book I'll think about it yeah
yeah you know what I'll think about it
thanks Christina
glad to help if I were theoretically
speaking of course to start my own
business what kind of advice would you
have to offer well I don't know there's
a lot of things you could do be
respectful to the people that you hire
sell what you know and are good at we're
gonna an industry with high demand I
sure know a lot about business basement
Spiros niche business actually I just
read a little blurb on the back of the
book see not bad advice but my main
opinion is just be bold and do it if
it's something you want to do of course
to be honest it's something I've
considered for a long time I don't know
it's just hard to imagine anything else
but this job at the moment the mine is a
blur well if it's something you would do
let me know I'll be your secretary let's
see you'd be hired in a heartbeat but
kind of hard to date my secretary
you'd be hired in a heartbeat really
don't be so cool I'd be really helpful I
promise I know you already kill it at
the office oh please I can do way more
than I currently do but I can run
Tyler's business better than he can then
we should start a business together and
we should do it together do what we
could be business partners really don't
be awesome I'd be pretty honored not
gonna lie that settles it if I ever
start a business you'll be the first
person I ask to be partners deal anyway
I'm gonna look for my book your business
or nah we should probably get back soon
yeah you're probably right
well things are going swimmingly here Oh
things were going swimmingly I think she
likes me guys ooh one last test one last
book to find what's going on oh man my
favorite Friedrich niche no don't see my
shame what's that oh my favorite author
you know what I'm gonna admit it if it's
my favorite author then I'm just gonna
say it's my favorite author Friedrich
Nietzsche
your favorite author is Friedrich
Nietzsche yeah believe it or not but I
read it at work all the time to clear my
head
dude this is the weirdest thing ever
yeah you know it's pretty weird when I
say it out loud no you're not gonna
believe this but I guess I kind of have
a confession to make huh
I am Fredrik ish you're not gonna
believe it but I don't read romance
novels I can't stand them I mean not
that I have anything against them
they're just not for me
uh-huh I do the same thing I read an
itch to clear my head at work oh my god
are you messing with me you cannot be
serious right now I'd say this you force
many to think differently about you that
charge they heavily to your account you
came nigh to them and yet went past for
that they never forgive you you could be
oh god this is so sappy we're quoting a
book together no I always loved that
quote I think I love you I love you
something I aspire to recognize it's
something I aspire to recognize I feel
like too often I hold myself back
because I'm afraid of what people might
think about me yeah I feel the same way
[Music]
[Laughter]
what are you doing oh sorry a little too
caught up in the moment it's okay
probably going don't you think yeah
you're probably right
Wow I [ __ ] that up well bye [ __ ] that
right up
oopsy poopsy oh [ __ ] there's no safe I
knew that was gonna be a goof joke don't
forget the coffee
oops oopsy poopsy if just forget that
ever happened oh my god nice be damned
Oh Frick who everybody awkward out of
this oh it's gonna swing swärje Oh Tyler
oh boy
you two better have a really good
explanation for this I needed a break I
just needed a break Tyler I'm good now
though good now though you're far from
it Sonny Boy
jeez Tyler relax it was my idea Frank
needed a break
hmm yeah sorry Kristina but you're fired
what what you just started the job a
week ago you can't fire her I can and I
just did secretaries are diamon dozen
even more replaceable than programmers
you don't deserve her anyway there now
rage which one I do see you know what
you don't deserve a secretary like her
she's too good for our company our
company ha ha ha don't make me laugh
you think you have any kind of stake in
this company I've been here for two
years Tyler I basically build this code
I know this business
in and out probably better than you do
christina is perfect for the company
she's smart honest and hard-working
get fire Frank don't worry about it I'll
be fine I knew Frank I'm tired of
thinking you have a say in the way I run
my business it's not your place you're
AI code and nothing else you got it
let's see don't talk to me that way
don't talk to me that way excuse me I
will talk to you the way I do fit now
get back to work no no excuse me I said
no I quit what we have deadlines I just
did good luck without me I'll be fine
without you Millennials they'll love
tech jobs good luck getting one new one
without my recommendation need I remind
you of this company's your only
experience in the industry you're
screwed right throw it in his face
though the coffee in his face right do
it scalding coffee and okay well that's
an option too
let's go Christina let's go sorry got
caught up in the moment
sorry are you sure you want to do this I
mean you don't have to quit for me
yes I do I can't bear myself to see
someone treat you like that well thanks
but I don't need your pity
oh wait that's not what I wanted [ __ ]
I've [ __ ] this up so what are we gonna
do now I see I'm gonna start my own
business you know what I'm gonna take
your advice and start my own business
really are you serious yeah you know
you're so right my code is basically
everything holding this company up
without a tit would be nothing I agree I
think you could do it I might need your
help bill really my help in what way
help me run it I think together we could
start and run a vastly superior company
to tyler's maybe we could even hire
Ronnie and Katy out from under him you
really mean it
I think it'll be tough but you know what
Nisha said whoa you guys are wide lift
can almost can bear almost any how oh is
that actually gonna be looking forward
to this new adventure Frank oh man I
stumbled through thee I stumbled through
the end zone but I landed and it was
good me too Christina oh yeah you forced
many to think differently about you that
charge they have a lead to your account
you came night of it oh yeah working
with your girlfriend yeah
oh hell yeah go Frank Takahashi Co my
guidance didn't get you very good but
hey it worked a little bit yeah so
anyway Betty's flicks and chill there
are more stories here I don't know
exactly how many but it's charming and
so so good
Danelle then I don't have to be on
rivers that perfect to have it work out
in the end
so there's rose there's Jose there's
Joachim Carruth there's oh oh no wait
that's that's the credits oh no no
there's only two more so anyway if you
guys want to see more of this game let
me know down the comments
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]